pour cette nouvelle vidéo de la série
dans son corps comme d'habitude on
accueille un invité qui vient nous
parler de sa particularité physique à
lui et aujourd'hui il s'agit de guy jean
[Musique]
mutine et humoriste auteur et comédien
salut luigi ça va c'est vrai et toi ça
va très bien alors est ce que tu peux
nous dire quelle est la particularité
physique
alors ma particularité physique j'ai du
vitiligo qui est une dépigmentation de
la peau
tu vas que l'ag autour des yeux sur les
mains sur les genoux
c'est quelque chose qui est apparue
progressivement que tu as de naissance
ouais c'est apparu disant petit à petit
en fait c'est apparu au bout des doigts
et après petit à petit ses montées comme
ça autour des yeux et tout le vitiligo
c'est une maladie qui se caractérise par
une dépigmentation de la peau sous forme
de taches blanches quand c'est apparu
comme ça tu l'as tu l'as vécu comment
bon en fait c'est bizarre je me rappelle
quand je les suis là prend fin quand
j'ai vu la première fois il anime une
émission sur mtv etc je passe au
maquillage et tout et je calcule jamais
tu as eu la cdu mais tu m'as pas moi qui
ai battus à la maquilleuse à regarder
tom dillmann si j'étais inquiet mais et
c'est à une petite tache un petit peu
plus clair là j'ai pas du tout elle pas
du tout et puis c'est du coup le soir je
regarde et je ouais j'ai une tâche un
peu plus clair et tout danger au niveau
je me renseigne vite fait ma chance je
vais chez un dermato qui me dis en toute
détente etoundi veut écouter vous avez
du vitiligo
on peut rien faire ça va augmenter dans
votre vie donc d'angleterre à directes
en trois secondes
il m'a mis une percute boom comme ça
j'ai dit oui et du coup tu es je suis
sorti je me suis dit vas-y un protocole
parce que c'est pas ça j'ai commencé un
peu à me renseigner tout ça en fait
c'est un truc qui est très souvent
héréditaire et moi mon grand père il
avait ça ok donc y en a ils s des
montres des apparts il m'a dit tiens je
te laisse du vitiligo
mais ouais donc et série glee terre
c'est sa part us a augment
ça continue et tu vas d'augmenter c'est
souvent par poussées d'accord
et moi je sais jamais quand on sait pas
quand ça va non ça c'est toujours une
mauvaise surprise tu as raté là et un
moment donné en plus souvent dans des
endroits où tu vas tu as l'habitude
d'être chez toi donc tu calcules pas et
tout arrive dans un hôtel la lumière
elle est un peu différente ou quoi et tu
es tu passes tu fais c'est que ça te
regarde encore une tâche entre le 8e
niveau touche moins d'un pour cent de la
population mondiale et il apparaît
généralement à l'âge adulte a
l'impression qu'il ya des des facteurs
qui accélère le les pousser à tuer
déclenché dans le stress web est resté
on dit toujours 60 hectares un truc
qu'on dit c'est le stress va mais c'est
vrai que moi je suis plutôt de nature un
peu enfin angoisse est carrément même et
donc ça m'étonne pas qu'on m'a dit ça le
stress il faut bien que le truc qui
reçoit quelque part donc voila voila
c'est ressorti après on m'a aussi dit
c'est un moment donné il t'arrive un
truc dur dans ta vie ou un truc marquant
est tout mouassa pas vraiment été le cas
mais du coup c'est plus le côté
héréditaire après le stress mais
peut-être ça augmente un peu j'ai pas
témoin je suis assez stressé tout le
temps donc donc je me rends pas compte
aussi si c'est ça ou pas qui fait honte
tu l'as vécu notamment quand ça a
commencé à toucher le visage par exemple
moi c'est un peu particulier parce que
tu vois j'ai la chance de faire ce
métier de d'imagés de bosser avec des
maquilleuses tout le temps qu'on les
tournages et eau au début j'ai eu un peu
un refus du truc tu vois je me suis dit
bon ça se voit pas vraiment plus ma
maquilleuse qui me dit mais non mais
regarde t'inquiète je te fais ça ça se
voit plus et quand ça va vraiment
commencer à quai de trois personnes qui
me disaient mais t'as quoi et tu vois en
allant au tournage
mam est que m 10e non mais on s'en fout
et tu prends ça tu te mets un tout petit
peu là ça se voit plus tu as et du coup
dans la facilité du truc et parce que
vraiment en plus j'avais des supers bons
conseils et hama vachement et des
maquilleuses tu vas et j'ai pas vu le
truc évolué déjà dans le sens où t'es là
au début tu dois juste faire ça pour
cacher un petit truc et puis après en
fait t'es tu dois faire deux petits
trucs et trois petits trucs tu te
retrouves
plusieurs années tels agents butin a
fait et après ça m'a vraiment vraiment
pris la tête
le mécanisme de la maladie est pas
encore très bien connu mais on pense que
ça pourrait être une maladie auto immune
c'est à dire que notre propre système
immunitaire s'attaque à certaines
cellules chargées de pigmenter notre
peau au quotidien
alors avant de sortir de chez toi ouais
tu m'as sous le masque est tout le temps
et ça ça a été un à refaire ce genre si
ça avait été un truc un choix de vie et
tout à refaire j'aurais vraiment laissé
se seraient arrivés petit à petit et
voilà c'est mais je te dis cela parce
que là maintenant j'arrive à en parler
j'arrive pas à ce tumulte trucs et
machins
chacun vit différemment de moi je te
jure que j'ai eu cette facilité à
camoufler et à ce qu'on montre vite fait
tiens voilà tu fais comme ça t'inquiète
syrien machin que finalement ouais je
les fais et après jeu masqué jeu masqué
jusqu'à ce que vraiment ça devienne une
fixette et que je puisse plus sortir de
chez moi sans je regardais ça se voit ça
se voit non ça se voit pas obtus avoir à
être dans une lumière ou que tu reviens
une autre à une autre là ça se voit way
jusqu'à tu m'énerves tout seul chez moi
parce que ça se voit et j'annule des
rendez vous je m'énerve contre les gens
je suis je suis là à deux mètres de toi
il ya de la lumière je vais me dire
[ __ ] en fait j'écoute pas moi moitié
ce que tu dis parce que je me dis ah en
fait il est en train de me coller au
train matt est il en train de voir il en
train de tu as donc c'était ça a été une
vraie galère quoi les mains tu peux pas
faire grand chose
et puis finalement en fait moi si tu
vois ce genre en fait si tu regarde au
niveau de mes mes bras tu vois jour là
se détachent idée plutôt bracelet plutôt
mignon mais en fait nous est tous arrivé
comme ça comme ça et puis finalement
c'est arrivé aux mains qu'en fait les
massawis je vois que ça se voie pas
l'impression ouais je sais comme ça mais
en fait en tee shirt ça se voit douvres
donc en fait je suis arrivé à un stade
où des dernières années là j'ai racheté
des sap avec des manches longues et
doblo plus que ça soit et si les genres
35° toujours de tee shirt débardeur et
tout avec poursuite comme ça d'un sage
craint pas la chaleur
alors qu'en fait ils te mettre en tee
shirt
il existe des traitements mais la
maladie a tendance à récidiver donc il
faut souvent recommencer ses récents le
fait que tu là tout maquis plus du tout
quand tu marques plus du tout les trucs
non je masque plus rien ces récents
ouais j'ai sorti en fait je savais pas
comment comment le gérer comment
l'annoncer je voyais bien que à partir
d'un moment ça allait être compliqué de
continuer à masquer ça se voit trop ça
me prenait trop de temps ça me bouffe et
la vis
et puis c'est passé des trucs en plus
qui font que tu dis est vrai c'est pas
si important que ça il ya des trucs plus
important mais en plus j'ai la chance
d'être madoff c'est ma femme c'est ont
toutes eu voix et du coup je me dis hein
ça je la fais chier plutôt qu'autre
chose d'être d'être comme ça je me rends
compte qu'il ya des trucs plus important
elle je sais que m soutien et que je me
dis bon au final voilà tu vois c'est qui
c'est des gens que mes potes des gens
que je connais pas voilà donc il a fallu
que je passe le pas et en fait je me
suis dit je vais faire une vidéo parce
que du coup bas et j'ai la chance de
voilà tu vas dans ce milieu c'est plus
facile on profite des réseaux sociaux
pour les bonnes raisons tu vois donc je
me suis dit c'est qu'on va faire une
vidéo il ya d'expliquer à tout le monde
ah qu'est ce que t'as qu'est ce que t'as
qu'est ce que tu as j'ai fait ce truc
parce que c'est vrai que mouassa arrivé
plusieurs fois qu'on me dise ah mais
qu'est-ce qui a été maquillé donc tu as
tes la wayfarer de tournage mais après
après j'ai eu cette phase où je disais
ouais je suis inquiet parce qu'en fait
j'ai une dépigmentation
tu vois étape 2 du truc tu es un
commentaire c'est le truc
et puis après voilà cette étape-là qui a
été de faire une vidéo pour dire pour
dire bon voila j'ai ça et surtout en
fait pour un évidement pour moi en tant
que thérapie pour ma vie de tous les
jours
mes proches pour c'est plus simple tu
vois je me rends compte vraiment je suis
en train de tout cas y'a plein de trucs
que je m'interdisais tu sais ce genre de
truc conde de thé quand tu mets ton
casque de scooter faut faire attention
quand tu mets d un truc tout con gillot
salon du jeu vidéo on m'invite chez sur
un stand steve et à l'époque on dit
ouais l'avait trompée réalité virtuelle
tu veux tester tu vas tout le moins
d'entrain de kif et toi tu es là ah je
pense ça n'a pas marché je te prends
envie de toi là tu as peu trop à la
piscine ou d'autres plein de trucs
ponthus va alors que ça me libère mais
du coup je me suis dit je vais faire
cette vidéo que j'avais tu vois tourner
depuis plusieurs mois mais je me disais
on verra quand j'ai envie de la sortir
et puis toujours tes je retarde un peu
le truc genre grâce malheureusement ma
chère et puis finalement oui je les
sorties g j'ai eu en fait que des
retours hyper touchant tu vois même de
bons déjà de gens que je connais c'est
qui qui disait mais ses coûts c'est avec
plusieurs trucs des on s'en fout tu es
con pourquoi tu faisais ça des vrais
proches qu'ils disent c'est qu'il le
prenne un peu ça leur fait de la peine
il dispute un méta ah ouais tu as ta du
talus ont duré ce truc tout seul tu vois
alors que nous on aura aidé avec plaisir
moi j'ai une première vouloir aider les
gens qui eux que jamais tous donc des
gens qui disent non en fait on s'en fout
grave et puis plein de gens que je
connais pas et tu étais je m'attendais
peut-être à ce que je me suis dit s'il
ya des gens qu'on du vitiligo et compass
est cette chance de pouvoir de pouvoir
être exposés de pouvoir dire des trucs
si je peux moi amener ma petite pierre à
l'édifice
c'est cool et puis finalement juste et
ça m'a étonné parce que j'ai eu plein de
gens qui m'ont dit ouais merci d'avoir
fait ça moi j'ai est pas en fait du tout
du vitiligo tu voyages en moi j'ai un
truc un autre truc à notre truc
et c'est vrai qu'il faut apprendre à
s'assumer à parce que dans la vie dans
la vidéo jeudi
il se dit en fait l'important c'est se
libérer tu vois et si tu de l'assun tu
te libères et dans ce cas là bas ça
tu te mets pas une barrière et arrête de
prendre la tête et quand je dis ça tu es
je suis en train de me rendre compte à
quel point parfois ça ça peut paraître
nul ou ridicule de dire hey mec c'est
bon t'as deux tâches ça se voit il y en
a ils ont des trucs de ouf
mais comme je dis toujours c'est un
complexe oui je sais pas rationnel et ça
se trouve genre tu as heidi klum mast et
tout le monde a un petit complexe où tu
te dis mais en fait c'est une bombe
atomique mais ouais mais moi je
souhaitais jeu complexe sur ce truc où
ce truc que tu vois que ça ouais mais
pas la globalité
ouais c'est ça alors je suis finalement
je suis content d'avoir sorti ce truc
est directement quand j'ai sorti ce truc
bah tu m'as dit je fais cette émission
que moi je regardais et gtdi en plus moi
ça reste je trouve que c'est hyper cool
ce que tu fais tu traites l'important
c'est de d'informer les gens le truc
c'est que le vitiligo c'est une
dépigmentation de la peau
c'est en gros tu peux plus bronzé et à
plus de couleurs en fait tu vois si ce
n'est que ça devient bon et c'est pas
parce que ça c'est la première question
que l'on se pose avec les histoires de
maladie peau c'est pas contagieux c'est
pas contagieux non c'est pas contagieux
c'est légal ben non c'est pas contagieux
c'est un pour cent de la population donc
forcément c'est pas hyper connue mais un
truc très important c'est justement et
pourquoi aussi j'ai voulu taire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui déjà on est dans une ère
où tu es tout le monde essaye de se
différencier un peu machin et je dis
ouais c'est important d'en faire une
force
what a difference est en fait une force
et justement je dis ça pourquoi parce
que moi ce qui m'a aidé c'est une fille
que je connais même pas
mais c'est oui nirlo qui fait partie de
ces trucs où la meuf elle a fait une
émission de top modèles aux états unis
elle arrive à la du vitiligo c'est une
bombe atomique
et finalement elle est repérée pour ce
truc là et le fait d'avoir quelqu'un de
public qui fait sa ba tu commences à
dire ouais bon en fait ça rentre dans le
vrai ami il a les cheveux roux lui il a
les cheveux longs lui il a un piercing
est là des tâches lui c'est tu t'en non
en fait t'es là dedans un truc ou où je
me suis dit tu sais c'est des gens comme
ça où il faut apprendre à vivre avec le
truc montrer que nous on s'en fout et si
ça peut aider des gens qui sont
vachement complexé des gens qui on
aurait bien aimé le faire ou quoi
il faut que je le fasse elle a du coup
avec le recul du coût quelques semaines
la coudraie masque bref est-ce que
talent que tu vois un changement dans le
regard des autres là peut-être plus les
gens que tu connais pas ou qui était pas
au courant qu'on peut
oh ouais alors en fait le truc c'est que
souvent quand je partais en vacances
loin et où je me maquillais pas tu vas
d'accord mais en plus on habite en
france et à paris on s'en doute a
toujours l'impression d'être un peu le
nombril du monde que les gens tu
regardes mach alors quand tu pars en
thaïlande et les gens ils en ont rien à
[ __ ] soit là pour kiffer leurs
vacances à leur strict et puis même les
locaux ils s'en foutent ils ont d'autres
problèmes tu vois donc ta petite tache
voilà donc ça avait commencé comme ça
après après quand je les fais et depuis
que je le fais ben non bizarrement je
vois pas de de vrais changements tu vas
c'est plus dans mon dans ma tête mais en
fait les gens à partir du monde tout
leur dis tu l'auras expliqué une fois et
puis ça a été cool ne pas devoir
expliquer à tout le monde comment il ya
ce truc de cette vidéo
non en fait c'est plus moi je suis libre
tu vois je me dis ouais t'es déjà je
suis de meilleure humeur parce que déjà
ça me prend plus la tête et je dors plus
parce que je te promets que c'est vrai
mais si je prenais des rendez-vous
l'après-midi on nous faisait waluigi
faut que tu viennes en tournage à 8
heures josé weight et parce que dans ma
tête je me disais c'est donc faux je me
réveille deux heures avant pour pouvoir
camoufler le truc que ça sèche que je
vois si c'est bien que ouais c'est un
ouais donc déjà ça me saoulait et les
gens en fait ils s'en foutent tant que
tu es bien tu vois toi demain tu me dis
elle regarde j'ai tel truc
bah si tu le vis bien et que tu es là
tiens partir du moment où tu me le dis
j'ai pu calculer
parce que si tu vas être tout le temps
être là jédir mairie qu'est-ce qui est
là tu as c'est quoi son arc en fait non
ça c'est c'est mais par contre moi mon
appréhension c'était d'arriver sur scène
ouais pas maquillée sur scène aussi tu
veux ouais ouais en fait je fais plus je
veux vraiment je jeu et en plus de ça tu
vois c'est vraiment ridicule parce que
moi je suis au jamel comedy club jamel
tu as il a le handicap que tout le monde
sait et ça ne l'a pas empêché de
d'être le meilleur tu vois donc moite et
j'ai un peu honte de me dire moi je me
prenais la tête pour ça alors que cit
avait un conseil à donner à quelqu'un
genre dans ta situation d'il ya cinq ans
ouais c'est quoi ton conseil franchement
ce serait c'est facile à dire comme ça
mais ce serait de l'accepter direct voie
de se dire bon on a tous des complexes
on a tous des trucs sur tout le vitiligo
s'est amené à iliad il ya une forme de
vitiligo qui qui évolue pas là c'est là
où tu vas faire le petit bonhomme si on
n'aurait pas le cas ce week end ils ont
été sifflés lui mais moi j'ai une forme
de meeting au qui est venu je sais pas
comment ça va évoluer et je me dis qu'au
début quand tu as un petit truc et que
les gens ils voient avec avec le temps
on voit que ça évolue tu calcules plus
ouais c'est toujours plus facile que de
dire regarde jamais rien et puis du jour
au lendemain boom en fait on regarde
donc ouais si j'ai un conseil je suis
personne et pour donner des conseils il
me permettrais jamais mais en tout cas
si je devais le refaire mois gd serais
tu ne crains pas je ne passerai pas et
ouais ça va voilà c'est du vitiligo c
c'est comme si tu as une marque de
bronzage à n'avoir jamais sauf qu'il y
en a elles ont des marques du stringer
bronzage la marque du truc
ouais voilà c'est une tache de naissance
sauf que ça arrive après que tu es né et
et sa part pas mais voilà et quand tu
vas en vacances ouais c'est ça ses côtés
au soleil pas forcément ça se voit plus
parce que du coup tu as le plus
un contraste plus chaud tu vas mois là
en ce moment dans période où il fait pas
été approuvé tôt donc j'ai eu un peu
blanchâtre donc ça se voit moins
cet été c'est que ça se fera plus mais
mais c'est pas grave c'est un truc comme
ça faut apprendre à vivre avec et si tu
as raison tu as ta force sa marque de
fabrique ton truc
et voilà atteint mukta un piercing tu as
une tâche s'en fout ça marche
merci beaucoup de mecs merci à toi à
bientôt est celui du coach postier
l'adar ce principe
[Musique]